yeah but like the i think the one thing
i like about izakayas is that
again like even people who don't drink
can still go to an izakaya and have a
good time
because as as you know we've established
like it's mostly like
drink based but the food a lot of the
times is also so freaking good
and cheap that you could probably you
probably won't have as much fun yeah if
you weren't drinking but
you could easily take your friend who
doesn't drink it all and they'll
probably still have a
you know a decent time right yeah
because like the food there you can
easily order
a lot of like snack kind of foods it's
like it's not like you have to order a
meal
yeah you know what i mean it's like a
giant [ __ ] pub burger yeah yeah
exactly
i will say that i do feel like the food
is a coin flip sometimes at the izakayas
you can normally tell which one's gonna
have bad food but
sometimes the food is just really bad
are you only saying that because you got
no okay
i did get food poisoning i did get food
poisoning very recently from me
but then the more i've been living in
japan and the more i've been eating out
at restaurants in japan the more i
realized like my god this food is so
much better than the izakaya food yeah
i'm like yeah it's fine yeah yeah you
know normally just sticking to karage
and
which is like the japanese boneless
fried chicken yeah yeah i mean yeah
don't get me wrong like the izakaya food
is good but there's definitely like if
you want problems
there's something like a proper
establishment there's sometimes there
are many kind i'm eating and i'm like
god this food is depressing
it's like really like there's one near
our where we're filming this that like
the
you know the one it was the underground
place yeah yeah yeah and
they had like the driest chicken i'd
ever seen in my life you'd think of like
they'd like left this chicken out to
like die in the sahara desert before
they like
harvested it yeah it was pretty anemic
yeah yeah everything on it was just kind
of like all right i guess you just
didn't love your job today
yeah the food yeah that that one is
definitely like it's it's not
horrible you know it's gonna be that
that bad when like the menu
everything is like 150 yen oh yeah well
you get what you pay for something right
right right but like comparing izakaya
food to some of the like the pub food
that i'm used to
i don't know i don't know i think pop
food's really [ __ ] good in the uk
am i really yeah maybe i'm too white to
make this point
i don't know because if i had a choice
pub food is where i
go if i like have no other choice or
whatever i can't be bothered to i
i promise right hand on heart if i had
to choose between izakaya food and
english pub food i'd go with pub food
really no joke no joke i've had food
joey's [ __ ] he's never gonna admit
that no no no no no no no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
no
i don't care about your opinion now okay
shut up for a second okay
fine okay like because it's the kind of
the same thing with australian pub food
as well
i don't know man i can't comment yeah
wild because australian because
australian pubs
uh it's kind of the same as the uk pubs
right where most people just go to drink
it usually it's very [ __ ] depressing
because it's just a bunch of like
middle-aged dudes who've been sitting
there since like 2 p.m
right just like wasting their life away
but like a lot of pubs
in australia they have really [ __ ]
good food but the problem is is that you
only get a set portion of food
for like a stupid amount of money right
right and so sometimes it's like a cost
thing
yeah well yes what i'm hearing is that i
smell
bro joey's
but the thing is that with australian
pub food a lot of it's good but it's
just like
you know even before you go into the pub
what food is going to be there
yeah yeah this is so little variety you
know same thing could be said with
izakayas
but i feel that it's always the same
[ __ ] in izakayas i don't know man like
different izakayas have different things
that they specialize yeah but then i
feel
the reason i love izakaya food is like
they're like designed to go
well with the beer or alcohol that
you're drinking it just it's just like
the perfect
it's like the synergy you were talking
about the pizza synergy i was right
about that by the way
it's it just synergizes so well together
whereas with pub food it's it's
it is like the same it's just like put
this in your stomach
i think yeah sometimes it is but not all
the time like there's been plenty of
these guys we've been to where i'm like
this is just weak
like this is mid as you would say joey i
mean i wasn't but even like
even like the mid izakayas are still
better than like
some of the best pub food i don't i
don't know i i just don't like pubs i'm
sorry england i don't like pubs you know
what
though i do really like irish pubs for
their food because i feel that at least
with irish pubs unlike uk pubs there's a
little more variety in the food and
there's
i feel at least from my experience i
feel like i took you to shitty pubs
though yeah
but i feel less pressure to get out of
an irish pub than i do at uk pub
if i'm not just sitting there drinking
well i like irish it's normally
what are you talking about in dublin or
yeah dublin and i went to something like
limerick and stuff like that all around
ireland yeah i mean the norm in the uk
uh apart from england because i think a
lot of england is just depressing
outside of the big cities
no offense um like in the small towns in
like wales and stuff there's some really
fun pubs because it's just like
20 yeah but i'm not going to go to wales
there's no reason to go to wales joey
i'm sorry
i'm sorry i'm sorry wales it's true we
have to accept that fact unless you like
i like ship do you like nature joey i
like sheep
all right do you like run down castles
do you like those um it's just hit or
miss for me
all right well you'll love where